I'm five two okay five six I'm getting
hit in the face that didn't go the way I
wanted it to be I have to get back up
Michelle Cara is known for her
unbelievable challenges where she's
trained for NASA the Secret Service SWAT
and FBI Academy 911 dispatch and
becoming a chess Grandmaster among
dozens of others but today she's
undertaking her most difficult challenge
yet fighting the chess extraordinaire
Andrea botes in Creator Clash's boxing
event and today you'll be getting an
exclusive behind the scenes I have never
trained harder for any video any project
I have gotten to when I was a
professional athlete right after you
subscribe but before we get into the
podcast I want to tell you about our
sponsor hostinger now first of all you
may notice Graham is gone that's because
he's about to watch Michelle Carrey
fight that's right jack but even more
exciting than that is hostinger that's
what Graham says that's right jack I'm
out of town right now but what's even
more exciting is hosting her a common
theme we've noticed amongst our guests
is the importance of having a website
but to be honest we had no idea where to
start looking for one that was until we
learned about hosting hostinger allows
you to launch a website or online shop
in minutes without any technical or
design skills and all for less than
three dollars a month and all of that
for less than three dollars a month it's
ridiculously easy to use even someone
like Graham can figure it out you can
launch a WordPress website with just one
click or you can use their super easy
drag and drop website builder plus you
get a free domain name included plus you
get a free domain name included and with
over 150 sleek and fully customizable
templates for e-commerce blogs
portfolios and landing pages you'll have
plenty of options to choose from and my
personal favorite part is that
hostinger's AI logo maker powered by
chat GPT allows you to create a free
logo in just seconds plus if you use
promo code iced coffee at checkout
you'll save 10 off your purchase so
check it out with the link Down Below in
the description or visit hostinger.com
iced coffee hour don't miss this special
discount and start building your online
presence today with hostinger welcome
back to the iced coffee hour my name is
Michelle and you are watching this
hopefully after I win Creator Clash
okay so what prompted this this is why
we wanted to bring you back on talk
about the fight you're fighting Andrea
botes right I am yes yeah chess expert
Andrea botes yeah I thought she's taller
like how tall are you I'm five two okay
five six
is that how is that a fair fight well
you know I I don't think there really is
any way for it any fight to be fully
fair right you know like someone is
always going to be at an advantage in
some capacity I have my athletic
background she has the genetic advantage
of height and weight but I've been
training my ass off and I've been
sparring people who I guess I can say
this now because it's after the fight
every person I have sparred is at least
six inches taller than me and 30 pounds
heavier than me I have not sparred
anyone who's actually my height is that
on purpose
so the one thing I didn't realize
like literally everybody you know what
you sure you should have fought Michael
Reeves that would be insane for the
video don't don't I would be the first
one of mine
you just win you just win automatically
honestly coming off a win last night
hopefully Michael you're next he would
he would honestly be perfect he'd be a
great sparring partner I would love yeah
honestly like last year for greater
crash one I was always joking like I
want to fight Graham really
oh my God no I wouldn't why not I I just
wouldn't do it I never want to fight
anyone again okay I respect I'm a one
and done that was it that is it but I
also think like for what we're doing
it's such a narrow Bullseye like I need
to find a female influencer with a
following who also has like comparable
boxing experience and like within the
height and weight realm like that is
such a narrow Target to hit and at some
point I just sort of realized like if I
really want to do a boxing match in like
the influencer boxing space I'm gonna
have to compromise somewhere and ideally
I wanted to find someone like 115 120
with all of those same specs but
you know I I think like life gives you
obstacles that just aren't going to be
perfect at the right time or the moment
that you want them and to me when this
happened I was like this is my
opportunity I just have to do it yeah
and as soon as you saw Creator Clash one
did you know you wanted to participate
in the second well I actually wanted I
was actually wanting to participate in
the first one honestly like I heard
basically so it was really coincidental
because I wanted to do an episode of
challenge accepted where I trained like
a professional boxer and
um you know enter a fight because I was
like how hard could it be to get in one
of these influence or things everybody's
doing it and so I connected with Tony
Jeffries who is an Olympic bronze
medalist he owns a gym here in Los
Angeles and we started training and he's
like you know there's this event coming
up in a couple months that I didn't know
about and it wasn't even announced yet
Creator clash and we sort of had this
like mini goal of like maybe if we train
someone will appear and you can get in
it didn't happen and so like basically
um from there like when you don't have
an opponent you can only do so much like
if you don't have an opponent and if
confirm right you're not gonna hard Spar
you're not gonna do two a days so like
yes we were training and training for
the hope of something coming through
whether it's creative class or another
promoted event but it did it so that at
a certain point I was like this is a lot
of time and money and energy I gotta
stop so after you know several weeks of
that I sort of just stopped and moved on
because trying to find an opponent was
such an ordeal who is a perfect opponent
for you who yeah like height and weight
no like what influencer celebrity or
someone that you picked out for example
Michael Reeves says he always wanted to
fight garyvee that's like his thing he
wants to take on Gary because it would
be funny exactly oh like it was yeah
um you know I actually haven't like
thought in that capacity of like who
would be the perfect opponent
um
I mean I think they're all there are
always people you want to fight
are they worthy of a fight
um yeah I mean I was thinking of more
than from like who's my hide in life and
that kind of sure perspective because
the the pool is already so narrow I
think
um Bell Delphine Bell Delphine would be
great yeah oh my God yeah that would be
cool that would break the internet
bellef that would be nuts yeah because
she's yeah I think she's like five five
right
something like that yeah a little bit
taller yeah
um yeah so I mean we did that
for last like spring and then crater
Clash happened and I was like I just
don't think this is gonna happen so I
did you apply or what was that process
like the first time you want to get into
it or was it sort of like
you know it was so close to the event
we're talking like
two months out from here oh God yeah
type of situation and Ian and Anissa
knew Tony because you know they did a
lot of like press events at the gym I
train at
um
and so I met them we trained together
and I think it was it's like a situation
of like this is literally happening in
eight weeks everybody is confirmed but
maybe next year so I stopped and then I
moved on to do like other things like
the other videos we had planned like
running a marathon in the desert and
training with secret service and stuff
so I wasn't like actually doing
really any boxing of any kind and then
when the chess boxing event happened in
December
um I saw Andrea's fight against Dina and
I thought it was amazing I mean it was
the most viewed section of the entire
stream the women's event
um and they went hard too I mean they
went like harder than the guys did I
feel besides dad dad
went bowling ballistic but besides that
and of course you know a big highlight
of last year was Haley versus me yes
it's so exciting amazing to watch and so
after the chess boxing thing I was like
hmm we're like not perfect height and
weight but I wonder if she'd be into
this so I actually called her like the
week after her fight when I we were
talking on the phone she was coming out
of a boxing class this was like three
days after her fight okay she just got
out of boxing class I was like oh my God
doesn't scare you the fact that she like
just like did boxing and then goes to a
boxing class right now she did her full
fight I know fought
and then you know coming right into cc2
of course that's something I take into
consideration yeah
um but I mean it was such an interesting
conversation because like at that time
there was an even bigger weight
difference between us
um probably like
in our original call I think we were at
it was a pretty big weight difference
like 15 18 pounds and we didn't have
anything confirmed at that point we were
just kind of like
could we potentially work towards being
opponents for each other
and see what happens
and she had also tweeted at Creator
clash and I was like you know maybe
maybe there's space for us in the event
this year it's four months out this time
not two months out let's see what
happens and at that point it was a no it
from from Creator Clash it was like we
have too many fights they're all full
um but Andrea and I were hopeful so we
made this like
verbal Pact
where we're like
just like kind of start training and you
know we'll be like kind of ready not
fight Camp not fight camp but like you
know obviously she's going to Boxing
class two days you know a few days after
her fight which is crazy yeah
um and you know I was like okay I'll
I'll call up Tony I'll call up some
people and see if I can just start going
a couple times a week
again and this is me coming out of a you
know pretty deconditioned State because
my wedding was in October and you know
as you're preparing for yours like it is
extremely time consuming it's stressful
especially like the month prior and then
the month after I felt like I was
recovering like I had not been
exercising at all sure and even though
we're releasing videos of me at Secret
Service whatever those were filmed way
earlier in the year
um and so I was like okay I'll start
going to boxing a couple times a week
and then you know when we heard about
um I did a thing and his
um injury
was when we were like oh my God it's go
time we can you know Anisa called us and
was like do you want to do this and we
were both like
holy [__] I guess so
um and so
it was
it was a it was a special opportunity
still last minute I mean we found out
about that
um prior to the public announcement but
like I want to say that our fight camp
like if when we officially were like
let's do this it's it was probably like
eight to ten weeks prior to this event
wow which is still compared to like all
the other Creator Clash athletes they
you know some of them found out the
night of CC1 like hey you want to do
this next year start training so they've
had a year they've had nine months
um and obviously like she and I have
unique and bizarre like
forthcomings with boxing her with chest
boxing in mind with like this like
little thing I did with Tony last year
um but not preparing either of us for
like a real boxing fight I thought the
chess boxing was like pretty real though
I know like taking the break and like
did she win I can't remember if she won
I think like technically on the night
they gave it to Dina because she won VHS
but then later right two days after
they're like well
Andrea pretty much won by Knockouts so I
think they yeah yeah yeah right
um yeah I mean the chess Box is always
extremely intense however it's it's
different training right because when
you're doing chest boxing the breaks
between each round of boxing are
significantly longer because you're
playing chess you know the table's got
to come down from the sky and you sit
there you play the chest and you put the
headgear back on it's probably like a
good five six minutes
physical rest break obviously your mind
is going a million miles an hour which I
can't do I'm never gonna chest box
Andrea
um but that's a different type of
training from like going all out for two
minutes one minute rest then back in you
know like it is for our face wow so how
has your training been the past eight or
so weeks it has been absolutely insane I
have never trained harder for any video
any project anything in my life I mean
this is the closest I have gotten to
when I was a professional athlete the
level of training and commitment and
time and what does that look like for
you well I guess I can share now you can
share it now yeah
I mean for me when when we got the full
green light it immediately was
six days a week two hours a day if not
two a days explain two days for us okay
so a two a day means you're going twice
a day to work out so uh typically that
means like early in the morning you go
and you do uh strength and conditioning
and then maybe in the afternoon you do
boxing or sparring but the the physical
benefit and I'm not a scientist here but
the physical benefit from my
understanding and my background in
athletics is that you are training your
body to you know have to recover
extremely quickly and go right back into
a workout
um and it can actually have like even
more benefit than doing two hours like
back to back splitting it up there there
are certain situations that it that it
makes sense to do that but it's like
putting your body in that state of
agitation more frequently with a with a
lesser rest period of you know eight to
ten hours rather than 24 hours got it
and so what do your workouts look like
so my workouts are I guess there are
four different types of workouts there
is you know your classic boxing mitt
work like what you see in all the Rocky
and Creed movies then there is cardio so
like get on a treadmill run sprints then
there's strength and conditioning which
is lifting weights throwing heavy things
around pull-ups push-ups
and then there's also recovery workouts
which is like what is a recovery workout
that's like spending an hour
um like doing stretching foam rolling
visualization has been a huge component
of this for me like literally I'll spend
30 minutes listening in my headphones
full-on crowd like sound effects really
relaxing with a blindfold on
and then I visualize this is what it's
going to feel like when they say hey
you're next
you're getting your hands wrapped
you go into the tunnel
the walkout song starts
the walkout begins wow this time
the Bell goes off
like
um
also visualizing like
I'm getting hit in the face that didn't
go the way I wanted it to be I have to
get back up you know like you visualize
the good and the bad moments
and like that's something I didn't
really do as much
um in my competitive athletic background
as a cyclist but for this it's so much
it's everything I feel Grimm says that
when he entered the ring like all of the
stuff that he trained for all the stuff
he studied and prepared for it just
completely left his mind as soon as he
walked in the room yep so part of me
feels like you can spend all this time
visualizing and stuff all that stuff
helps but might have to do that Jack is
you know that the boxing part like no I
didn't I didn't do any of the uh the
mental stuff I was just like block it
out wow no I did not want to confront
that almost feel like a blur sometimes
or like a blackout in a way kind of wow
yeah yeah I mean I would say that the
crowd and the adrenaline are two things
that you can try to get close to I mean
like for example I guess I can say this
now when I'm sparring they on the on
like the overhead speaker system blast
crowd sound effects Extremely Loud at
one point like our coach in the corner
is screaming at the top of his lungs to
try and communicate try this try this
try to simulate that but also like I no
I'm in the safety of the gym I you know
what I mean like it's not the same as
like you're walking out and you see
people cheering for you see some people
booing for you like those sounds of like
hearing someone else's name cheered when
you're getting your ass kicked yes yeah
and replicate that yeah I don't want to
say it was tough for me but definitely I
think the crowd favored Michael by like
because it's Michael like I would be
rooting for Michael
but it's when when like you get that
punch and everyone's like whoa look at
the Michael like it it's it's tough to
overcome that too like mentally because
you don't like you kind of hear it and
it seeps into your mind but you don't
really focus on it but it's there yeah
for sure and I'm prepared for that too I
mean Andrea's audience is huge it's a
streaming audience they're extremely
engaged I'm sure she has plenty of
friends social media people who are
coming to support her as well yeah
um yeah it's gonna be tough and I would
say at this point like I am I'm
extremely confident in the physical
ability the training the conditioning
all of that but that one variable I
think will be
the unexpected for everybody at night
what's it like for you to spar sparring
how many how many times have you Spar
like what's what's that process like so
walk us through the beginning to like
the most recent I guess if I had to
count
sparring three times a week wow
eight ten weeks no way 30 times I don't
even that's a lot yeah Michael sparred
like 12. and I was like four wow yeah oh
my God that's bad yeah I mean that's
really tender trade but really
impressive but for having only four
times sparred to get in there and do
that yeah I don't know I don't know
about that but I think people this time
are taking it way seriously way more
seriously because the first time we had
no idea what to expect and we're like ah
it might be a bit of a uh whatever but
this time I think people are looking
back and and seeing how seriously they
took it and like yeah I got it one up
that now absolutely I mean the first
time I sparred and this is covered in
the video that that I'll be releasing I
had a panic attack fully like getting
hit in the face and like you forget
everything I I don't think people get
that like the when when you're working
on the mitts Translating that across the
bridge to sparring is a journey in and
of itself like you could literally train
the same thing on meds as as maybe you
experienced a billion times and then to
apply it and sparring can take weeks you
know it's like when you're in there
under the pressure of like I'm not just
like hitting clean myths with my trainer
because now there's someone else's arms
in my face and my eyes and coming back
at me at the same time like so many
other variables
and when you're not in a controlled
environment and working through that
um but you know I feel fortunate that
that happened to me pretty early on
and
I adjusted and worked through it so now
sparring I feel at this point is more
like
it's a extremely intense workout and
nothing compares to it
um but I don't have the like
fear in that capacity have you gotten
hurt
[Laughter]
any of this
before the fight because yeah it's been
strong I'm perfect it's not been perfect
in any capacity I have
um throughout the past 10 weeks I
everyone in our office had this crazy
ass flu
so I was sick for a week
um I have a few years ago I was in a car
accident so I have this recurring neck
like nerve pinch thing where like I get
smearing pain all down my spine oh geez
it's fine yeah but that happened to me
during one of the spines it really
activated that didn't post any of that
this is the reality of this yeah what
are we posting me and Andrea are like at
the gym like everything's going awesome
that's what you're posting and that's
not fully the reality
um so I had to go to PT for that I
rolled my ankle sparring
um yeah I mean it's crazy but that's
part of it you know it's part of it and
then also playing the poker face of
nothing's wrong yeah yeah that was a big
one for me every time I was tired I was
like no you're not gonna do that you're
going to be like getting up and like
doing the doing the jumps a little bit
Yeah like you can't mentally just sit
down or put your arms on the uh on the
ropes because then it's like it's gonna
make you more tired the day that I
rolled my ankle it was like round two of
sparring and I think we had six rounds
that day they're like you keep going
because if this happens in the fight you
need to work through that and I finish
the whole thing
and then I went couldn't that just make
it worse though like that might prevent
you from like sparring the next day
correct um but it I I feel like I'm so
like at this point athletically in tuned
with my body I would have known but like
I was like I can do this yeah um but I
mean the recovery part is a whole thing
like I sit in an ice bath every single
day
I sit in a sauna hot tap like it's it's
a full thing yeah I mean oh my God so
this is like a full-time job almost
because this is like two hours of of
exercise and probably another hour of
like visualization baths whatever so
it's like and maybe now we're getting
ready for it so that's like four hours a
day it's a lot yeah and then the drive
to and from the gym and then when you
get back you gotta shower it's it's
extremely time consuming and so I feel
really fortunate because we just hired a
head of operations for our Channel
so that allowed me to
like give a lot of responsibility to him
like I literally could not do this
without that hire and we also hired a
second editor so like we had a team
meeting at the beginning of all this
basically saying like this is what
Michelle's life is going to be like for
the next eight weeks and this is how we
as a team are going to adapt to it and
support and what responsibilities still
are mine versus not and that was
extremely helpful that's cool what's
something that happened that was
unexpected in your experience of boxing
so far in like the eight weeks and
fighting random people and putting your
body through this I guess and I'm I'm
not just saying this because like this
is coming out the day after we'll see
what happens
it's interesting to me because at the
beginning of all of this I was I was
transparently extremely concerned about
the height and weight difference
um I mean I've had to gain muscle and
she's had to come down
um and that is a variable that I don't
have control over
um but and so when we when we set out to
do this and like you're only going to be
sparring people that are at least six
inches taller than you Andrea's four
interest dollar and they have a longer
reach they're going to be at least 30 40
pounds heavier than you that was really
hard it's really hard because like with
that difference you are fighting uphill
constantly you could have perfect form
and Miss every time just because the
difference in the reach yeah you have to
have even better cardio because you're
running around the ring more you're you
know have you have to have way better
head movement
um
when when you are a smaller shorter
fighter and so that was a really big
hurdle for me to overcome but at this
point I feel
really confident with it only because I
don't know what it's actually like to
spar somebody my actual height and
weight look at Mayweather and Logan Paul
though yeah when they fought I mean you
saw a huge size difference like it was
massive that was what like 10 inches and
like 30 40 pounds yeah it was nuts but
Mayweather was like you could I believe
he was kind of holding back yeah he was
kind of almost like holding back a
little bit I heard though that um I
think Michael called it the turtle uh
where you would Crouch down and make
yourself lower yeah you have the
advantage of being lower to the ground
it's harder to hit
I hope so I mean if she if she's
crouching down she's more like eye level
to you yeah if you're crouching down
She's Gotta punch down exactly harder to
do I mean we've done a lot of work like
getting on the inside Bodywork coming
off on an angle that's like a lot of
what I've been training you'd have an
advantage like get down underneath and
then do an uppercut because she she
couldn't she couldn't do that it's all
you got to do get down do the Crouch
turtle come on up Duck and shoot between
her legs
so let's hear some predictions
predictions how do you think this is
going to go yeah I'm pretty confident
I'm going to win you're pretty confident
yeah I think so based off of Just My
intuition I think it's gonna be uh not
even close I think you're gonna win oh
well thank you you're welcome I think I
should very much be eating my words
yeah I mean um yeah honestly at this
point I think the the nerves of the
crowd and the events leading up to
Saturday are really the the one variable
I'm most concerned yeah do you meditate
I yeah I mean the visualization for me
is meditative but this is I probably
should like yeah I think you should yeah
I think you absolutely should yeah yeah
um but what's really cool is like
I feel that when I was actually like
assigned pro athlete
I did not have any of the resources that
we have now when I am a content creator
like being able to hand things off to
other people I mean as a as a female
athlete you don't you're not paid like
that you don't have the ability to
to do that because you're just like the
difference in pay is so vast between
male and female athletes that like now I
feel like I'm actually getting to
experience what it's like to be not a
pro athlete but like I get some of those
luxuries by being a content creator we
all do I mean we're pretty much everyone
who's in creative class we have a huge
privilege of having people to to support
us and we have like this really
bizarrely warm and welcoming environment
with Creator Clash which I have never
experienced in any other athletic
Community it's amazing we're like we're
all in a chat and everybody's like you
guys look great at training how's it
going you know the Discord group yeah
yeah I I have never experienced that in
any other athletic community and so it
it really feels like an amazing
opportunity and honestly no matter what
happens like I am extremely proud of of
what
I'm extremely proud of first of all of
Andrea being willing to do this with me
so that there is another women's fight
on this card period And I want
more
more people to feel inspired to take on
challenges whether it is against you
know me versus Andrea I'm going up
against an opponent genetically
advantaged over me I want people to
hopefully take away from that maybe I
can
attack this thing that I have been
scared to do before or maybe people see
someone like me or Andrew a chess player
going in to do this it's I just hope
that we can you know follow in the
immense footsteps of people like Amanda
Serrano and Katie Taylor who have really
paved a lot of way for for women's
Athletics and even though this is a
charity boxing event just like being
there and being willing to do this I
mean I really got to give it to Andrea
too that like both of us agreeing to do
this on such short notice is a crazy
thing and I hope that regardless of the
outcome the
um of the fight that the outcome of the
event is one that is extremely positive
and inspiring what's the scariest part
about it for you oh
oh my God
there's Fists
I think the scariest I think like my
biggest fear is going in there and then
feeling like I didn't give it my all in
the end or I let the crowd get to me or
I saw you know her team in the corner I
heard them saying things like Michelle's
tired go go go you know like if I let
those things get to me to me that is
going to be the biggest failure not like
the the win or the loss whatever the
biggest failure is to like leave that
ring and feel like [__]
I
I could have tried harder in that moment
what's interesting to me is I draw the
parallels between obviously your YouTube
series The Challenge Accepted where you
go do all these crazy things all the
time and then your ability to hop into
the ring is such short notice what do
you think it is within you that gives
you the courage or bravery or confidence
it may be to go and do all of these
things I think it's actually
excuse me I think it's like a learned
skill set of how to approach an obstacle
in such a short amount of time because
for me like having done so many of these
challenges like I know day one I'm gonna
feel this week three I'm probably gonna
feel this when I start self-doubting
okay I know this is part of the process
whereas like other people doing Creator
Clash I feel like those might be newer
experiences but in the same way you guys
can sit down and do a podcast
effortlessly or like Graham can like
pick a stock and then make a million
dollars in a day or whatever no you know
what I mean yeah
like those are learned skill sets and
and for me I think my competitive
Advantage is just like the skill set of
putting myself in an uncomfortable
situation and knowing all those like
random cues are part of the process so
it's challenge accepted becoming less
challenging for you no
that's [__] scared okay but how do
you top that like you can't just keep
going down this Rabbit Hole physical
activities that you're putting to get
used to like you said it's a learned
skill and once the muscle gets so strong
any new challenge physical activity
mental activity something like that
could maybe become a little bit easier
right
approaching uh approaching the next one
becomes easier but the process is is
still extremely hard
I mean
it it could
um I guess what you mean about like what
does this mean for future episodes how
do you where do you go from here and to
me it means delving into parts of myself
that are less comfortable to explore
such as uh mental challenges like when I
did ironically my chess challenge
accepted that was actually the hardest
one I think I've ever done I I honestly
think that was harder than boxing
um and I think it just offers
opportunities for us to explore other
types of challenges that exist in the
world all around us and what about diet
for you oh diet oh my God diet has been
a huge part of this I know both for me
and Andrea because Andrea's coming down
and wait I'm having to
um you know make weight at a certain
point by gaining
um so yeah we have like a private Chef
that delivers meals every three days and
they're all like calorie macro carb
counted and I just eat it and go to
sleep really yeah
how much is how much is that chef
um
that Chef is probably 300 a week it's
pretty expensive that's not as bad as I
thought no
yeah when you account for like the level
of training that you're doing and the
importance of that yeah I mean it's
amazing highly recommend her name is
Chef Bernardi it's not bad I mean if you
consider that you're not like actually
wait hold on I was accounting for both
myself and Garrett oh it's I guess it's
like 150 175 a week
that's not bad that's not bad at all if
you're not going out to eat like no
dinners and stuff like that it's not bad
I compared it to like yeah I got every
meal on Postmates well lunch and dinner
on Postmates it's cheaper than that and
healthy and I I don't have to think or
like like for example when I when I was
a signed athlete I was sitting there
like cooking all my meals and like
putting stuff on a scale measuring yeah
to have that mental load off is so great
really yeah I want to try that yeah you
want to try no it's it's that that sort
of meal plan yeah because for me besides
all you could eat sushi I don't care
about food I just kind of eat it's a
feel like to feel kind of hungry
yeah yeah but like if I could just be
like this is just all I eat these are
the times and I just do it without
thinking about it I wouldn't mind it the
the not having to think
it's everything yeah not having to cook
yeah I want to get down to like under 10
body fat like that that is my that's my
goal ten percent
six-pack have you had abs before once
really yeah
oh gosh I'm sure I'm sure
oh man I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure I
could find it somewhere yeah but that
was I was I must have been like 25 25 I
was 25 so then like the best shape of my
life but that's when I was doing nothing
but work and gym and that was it was
that free YouTube the pre YouTube okay
but I was spending an hour to an hour
and a half a day in the gym while also
eating really really really healthy like
I took it so seriously I cut out carbs
like carbs for me were a big one the
only carbs I'd have is uh oatmeal before
a workout oatmeal and honey and then
everything else was just like chicken so
really into nutrition at that point how
are you eating your chicken where are we
getting it from
I was about to say Trader Joe's it
wouldn't be that uh Ralph's Ralph's you
just were you baking it what were you
doing no I think it's like I think it
was like the pre-packaged chicken yeah
and then oh lots of eggs too what what
do you do currently for food do you
order do you Macy Cooks no she cooks she
cooks maybe two to three times a week
the other times Chipotle
sushi
herbs and Rye herbs herbs and Rye I mean
it's we're going out to eat way maybe
more often because if we're home all day
it's just like you want to get out of
the house it's like the one thing we
could do every day together that I'm
looking forward to after finishing work
and like getting out of the house
so
it's just but I I like all you could eat
sushi that that's for me the biggest
hard thing to turn off of that's all you
can eat sushi yeah once you get used for
thirty dollars it's such a good deal and
then your shout outs to Sushi Neko Sushi
Ken Goku is the other one but it's
smaller this is in Vegas yeah thirty
dollars
oh yeah well our trees thirty dollars I
have a question so do you think during
someone's life at some point they should
get a six-pack because I heard this now
now I heard Andrew Tate said of all
people and I'm not everyone
[Laughter]
nor disagree with this but someone
reached out to him and they were like
sad or something I saw it when I had
Tick Tock three months ago you deleted
Tick Tock yeah delete tick tock
Instagram and YouTube I deleted Tick
Tock I did weeks ago man I know you guys
posted weeks ago yeah
shout out to Josh thank you Josh
Instagram too is good to get rid of yeah
if you can manage yeah no I do a lot of
networking on Instagram I do too okay
anyways he said something like someone
reached out they were sad and they were
like what do I do to fix my my sadness
or whatever and he's like get a six-pack
then come back to me I was depression so
you know what I'm talking about I do I I
kind of agree with it you agree that if
someone is nice that they should get to
the point of getting a six-pack and then
their sadness has not yet been fixed or
at least not fixed but like improved to
some capacity then you think here's what
I think and I'll let you share this
um I think unless you have like a strong
chemical imbalance in which case
whatever you do is not going to fix it
like going to the gym could only make
such a big difference sure I feel like a
lot of people not everybody I think
there are certainly cases where it's
warranted for medication but I think in
a lot of cases people are down they're
just not motivated I think going to the
gym getting that six-pack gives them one
Focus that all they have to do is do
that one thing and and having a goal
that they hit is going to give them so
much momentum to hit the next one and
the next one then you get that six you
know upward success like a success
spiral so I think that helps so I'm glad
that I don't sound crazy because I
actually kind of agree with that to a
certain amount as well because I was not
taking care of my body at all and I was
in like one of the worst mental places
of my entire life like I'm not working
out I'm not feeling good in my own skin
and then all of a sudden I start taking
care of my nutrition and I start working
out and all of those sadness and
ailments and whatever like they start
not disappearing but definitely becoming
smaller and smaller to the point where
like they're not even a big problem
anymore so it's kind of interesting like
you take care of yourself you know you
get a little bit of a six-pack I don't
have a six-pack but I feel good amounts
of working out we know uh and it kind of
like it kind of helped it absolutely I
mean we the longest relationship you
have is with your body so
if you're not it's like a car if you're
if you're not gonna wash it or put the
right gasoline in it it's not going to
function properly if you don't get a
tune-up every now and then I definitely
think like what whatever I I'm not going
to agree with Andrew Tate on anything
but like you know I understand the
perspective of if you're if you're
feeling mentally down maybe taking care
of the physical could help in that
capacity for sure and it's interesting
because it's not only just like feeling
down but also like motivation feeling
like other random obviously positive
emotions like I was not feeling
motivated at all and I was trying so
hard to force motivation on myself but I
couldn't feel motivated but as soon as I
fixed my like sleeping habits my diet
and my physical exercise problem then
all of a sudden motivation was easy to
find yeah it's like you can't
necessarily attack all of these other
like non-tangible things such as being
motivated or inspired in Life or excited
right and happy all the time you can't
chase those things I feel like you have
to chase the root problem which could
sometimes be nutrition diet and like
water intake and exercise and it also
like releases chemicals in your brain
that that that make you feel better and
um you know adrenaline serotonin all of
those things are really good for your
mental health too yeah I've always found
that I have more energy when I work out
yeah
I was worried when when I did this uh
you know training for Creator Clash that
a lot of business stuff would get put on
the back burner and ironically like
literally like 30 things that we've been
waiting on for a long time have just
come through the pipeline because when I
get home from training I'm like Bam Bam
Bam I'm in the headspace of let's go
yeah and it's it's really interesting
once you like turn up the heat in one
area of your life how everything else
sort of
Rises to that too I agree when I had the
most energy I've ever had in my entire
life and motivation well not motivation
but probably energy was when I was
running cross country competitively in
high school and I was running like 12
miles at 9 A.M on a Saturday and then
obviously be tired from like you know 11
after the run until one but then after
one I'd have so much energy throughout
the rest of the day it's interesting uh
what does your husband think of all of
this
okay
I was like I don't know
I don't know who doof this and he's like
let's go we're gonna be amazing he's
extremely supportive
um but then you know a couple weeks and
I was like you gotta like how do you
actually feel about this he's like
obviously I'm really freaking nervous
for you but I can't I'm not gonna say
that you need to be in the headspace of
let's go
um but he is the
oh my God most supportive partner
creative collaborator
business partner of all time yeah he
he's the one I'm like I get home I'm
like okay it's noon I need to get on my
computer he's like you need to go lay
down for a half hour
go and it it's it's really amazing but
he is so excited he's going to be there
he's going to be ringside oh he's
ringside yeah like because our
production team is coming oh got it okay
so he'll be with them
like Sim like wherever the cameras are
allowed got it not in the corner okay
he's got to be freaking out internally
though probably yeah and he's putting on
a good mask of just like uh you know
what I'm going I was watching Macy
because I was sitting right next to her
in the first Creator class
she was like like a chihuahua you know
how they like shake uncontrollably
that's literally how she was just like
shape I would I would Pat her on the
back I would feel the same way until the
exact same way I couldn't do it yeah
they're not gonna do this at Creator
costume like in in Pro fights when they
cut to the families
of the fighters that's crazy yeah yeah
I'd be I'd be a mess like mental
mentally yeah I'd be so I'd be so
worried geez yeah it's just like because
you never like I always go for like that
worst case scenario
forbid like any if anything happens it's
like I would this feels so bad and like
I was just nervous and like I get I just
get anxious for things like that like
anything that involves like getting hurt
or punched like even for me I was like I
don't want to get like any sort of
damage at all so I'm not worth it right
yeah and I felt like honestly it was a
blessing in disguise the first grader
classroom workout because I was you know
six months before my wedding and one of
the reasons why even when I didn't have
an opponent we weren't going like full
speed because
Tony was like
if you don't get a fight it's not worth
it and your wedding is this year so that
makes sense you want to have a yeah a
good looking nose for the wedding
pictures yeah
what was that like getting married in uh
you got a week to plan for the whole
thing yeah so I mean
what the wedding stuff was was amazing
it was
such a special experience I'm so excited
for you and I I feel like
a lot of people approach what like
content creators approach weddings like
let's do 28 Vlogs on the process and you
know really get what we can out of it
and I was sort of like I feel like
everybody's done Vlogs and and whatnot
and so I wanted to do something that
would actually like if we're gonna film
it let's Elevate the process so I had
this crazy idea like what if we just
plan the entire thing in one week like
clear our schedules forget this whole
like after work we're on the phone
trying to figure things out when we're
tired like just take a week and plan the
whole thing because we lined up all the
vendors and it was literally the best
thing ever highly recommend to anybody
getting married because
Monday to Friday it was done and then
the rest of the engagement we were just
like chilling it was so great every
decision was done we knew exactly the
budget for everything like we went right
from picking the florals to picking the
centerpieces so it was all fresh in our
heads
and but how far in advance did that week
occur the week occurred and then when
did you get married relative to that um
we filmed that I want to say in February
or March of last year and then we got
married in October so we had been
engaged we got engaged right before the
pandemic and
throughout the pandemic we couldn't
really do anything and so we were
waiting like
for things to be uh I guess like
available to us to do so now I'm just
curious because obviously I'm totally
ignorant to you know throwing a wedding
I don't want to be that guy but I'm just
curious I see that look how exactly
where this is because here's the thing
you pick a spot you get a nice picnic
area yeah you call your friend that
maybe is a part of a band or something
like that they come along tell them some
songs to play you get a DJ find one on
Craigslist you get of course I don't
know you get a florist somebody that can
supply flowers you call your local Taco
Truck they come if you want to serve
tacos if you don't totally fine I'm
serving tacos
it's like and then you send out the
invitations
how could it be a Monday through Friday
process like what do those hours look
like like our vendors like why does it
take five days yeah
yes absolutely if you're doing
everything if you're like let's just say
like you guys sit down to make your
wedding website for your guests there's
a website yeah you need a website for
people to RSVP to and to collect their
meal preferences and the registry for
people to buy you gifts if you want that
and you you know you need to have like
hear all the hotels and the
recommendations and for all the people
who are you know spending money to fly
out to wherever
um collecting all that just making the
website
that's like a four hour process of going
on you know
the knot or whatever entering manually
every single person's name address email
phone number dietary restrictions doing
all like that's four hours then you know
driving somewhere in LA to meet with a
florist that's two hours just to pick
the flowers oh you're like meeting them
well to film it for sure oh sure and we
go you go to the floor flower shop and
you're like I like this tulip and I like
that like that driving all over the city
going to the place where you rent chairs
sitting in all the chairs picking the
chairs it's time consuming wow okay so
you're sitting in there you know it's
like when people talk about wedding
details this is why people get stressed
out God I wanted to create an
environment like
let's just only focus on this and get it
done that makes sense I think just as a
person I'm a lot less like like I don't
have taste you know so I just I'd say to
the and then no other way to say it but
I'd call the florist and be okay pick
out the flowers good for a wedding call
the chair people really pick out chairs
that are good for the wedding it's a
very guy there's a very good I think
that they're gonna be like what do you
want I'm gonna ask you a question let's
go for comfy yeah you just you should
just give them a a budget it's like hey
I want to spend x amount just give me
whatever this will buy okay but then the
colors okay so like let's say they pick
the flowers I just said everything's
white okay everything's white yeah then
you have to communicate to all the
groomsmen all the Bridesmaids your you
know the wife like your outfit is
impacted by that if you care about those
things you don't have to I personally
you don't have to I feel like my wife
probably would you know
I think a lot of the the yeah I think
women grow up and they had this vision
of like having this wedding and they
think about it since they're a kid and
they want they want to live after that
that was the opposite of me really I
could not care less I was like I just
you know married what is it I don't know
like I just I was I'm I've always been
so career focused that I just don't care
and I was like what is the point it's
it's so much money it's so much time and
everyone gets stressed out and seems
really stupid
um and ironically Garrett was like this
is going to be such a special
opportunity for us let's have fun and
sure we'll make some videos about it and
see if that helps cover the cost of it
and everything so it's how much did the
wedding cost
I'm not going to tell you how much it
costs but I can tell you let's say it
cost one gold coin
via the content we created we not only
paid for that one gold coin but made two
more gold coins
wow she paid for it three times over
yeah
it was that's smart is that is that
through sponsors or discounts on the
wedding because of okay hmm okay so
Graham has this uh this idea okay he
wants to sell tickets to his wedding
what to like a viewer or somebody in the
wedding to your family
just like to viewers so he wants to have
like a viewer's table or something like
that I personally don't like the idea
but here's the thing it's going to be
the wedding cost gotta be like 30 grand
35k like something like that all in for
everything that's your budget is what
you're saying yeah gosh the budget
initially was like I want to do this for
like 15. but very quickly we realized
you can't do that my thought I can't
make a profit from
a wedding doing like sponsors or selling
tickets to it I couldn't do that if I
were making videos about it with with a
sponsor in the video I could do it but
not like the wedding itself like I just
wouldn't feel right about monetizing
that negotiate that like this is my
wedding video it's going to be three
times the cost of what it normally is if
you want it if you want to be in my
wedding I don't I don't want to monetize
it though it's it's something for me
that it's not like an interest to like
film it and have to think about like
making a video on it absolutely and
that's why like we sponsored the and
monetized two of the videos but like the
actual video of the wedding is like
there's copywritten music like we were
like this is oh yeah I know but my idea
with tickets was to sell like really
expensive tickets but just make that go
towards charity so it's like if it's
like 10K a ticket or something like that
because what we want to do instead of
gifts is is have everybody donate to an
animal shelter or like adopt an animal
or something like that yeah it would be
weird if it's like hey guys I want pots
and things
we don't
I don't know what we you know we're I
think you know all of us at this table
are extremely privileged to be in a
different position than I think many
people getting married are so
um
yeah I love that idea but it might be
different if I could make a video about
the wedding and then write it off as a
business expense because yeah because
then I could be like well this is a
production for YouTube the channel
I will say and then definitely a
strategy you know yeah because because
we could have like a like a wedding
wedding
you know the marriage itself but then
like hey this this is an event that we
are hosting for a YouTube video everyone
agrees to be on the YouTube video yeah
that's smart yeah and then you like
don't have to pay some videographer to
make a wedding video you just have Alex
do it
[Laughter]
I hate this thumbnail the thumbnail
should be like basically running away
from the wedding and me like left at the
altar and be like it went horribly wrong
yeah would you wear yeah a hat that just
says yeah a public on it
flip it backwards when you're going for
the
kissing people do that we didn't do
anything people do that I mean people
have like elements of their weddings
sponsored for us like we were like no
brand is going to touch
it's about the wedding yeah yes but like
sure if you want to pay premium for a
mid-roll in in this like wedding
planning video
makes sense right before the kiss occurs
on that husband and wife
imagine this I Now pronounce you husband
and wife right after we announced
today's sponsor
and then it's like what is it a rage
you know every happy marriage is uh you
know your guys are playing raid Shadow
Legends listen you gotta make your your
penny somewhere and I don't knock
anybody that does that
not my personal way of approaching it
but no I I'm probably more on your side
yeah
yeah there's a lot of options there we
got a year you know so yeah strategy hmm
that's less to think about you said you
hired a head of operations yes so what
exactly does that position look like
yeah so I mean hiring the head of
operations was like a huge process and
decision for us but it was actually
inspired by yes Theory so yes Theory I I
just think that the way they have run
their company and organization is really
admirable and something that I feel like
we as creators occupy this unique space
where yes we're talent but we're also
business owners and running like a
production company or a commercial
company in a way and so when you are
represented by like
like a like a traditional capacity where
someone's taking a percentage of
something to help you grow your career
at a certain point that number exceeds
the cost of a full-time employee and we
were sort of at this like crossovers
where it's like we want challenge
accepted to develop into its own brand
clothing act aware and
operate more like a production company
and so ahead of operations for us
was like a really exciting hire and we
actually
um you know someone that we know worked
for Lauren Michaels who created SNL
created SNL yeah and like all of the
ancillary films from SNL properties
um so he he worked at his production
company and we somehow convinced him to
join our team as our head of Ops
um which was a crazy process by the way
um but basically what heavy Ops does is
like oversee the operational aspect of
the business so like
um how to like there's like a whole
sheet of responsibilities he has but
they range from like scheduling our
weekly meetings making sure videos get
out the door uh one-on-ones with all of
our employees uh anything it's like
editing oversight as well
um not in a creative capacity but in
like a let's sit down with the editors
and develop like schedules for
everything so he like previously it was
me sort of running and overseeing making
sure everybody was hitting their Mark
and now it's him and he's also I'll be
like hey can you reach out to this brand
to do this thing or oh let's you know
rather than always going through like a
traditional Ad Agency type thing we have
an internal person who's thinking about
that 24. you haven't and this guy will
manage them or whatever or yeah he he
like oversees all of our brand deals he
like any client interaction is through
him that's right now which is really
nice huh yeah
yeah the crazy challenges you have
coming up in the future what do we have
coming up let me think so boxing and
then after boxing I think I told you
guys about the butler Academy last time
you did yeah finally coming in I can't
wait for that one it's been a long time
I would just be like churning these
videos out I know well I mean it's too
long to wait for Butler Academy and
transparently yes it is you should take
that Butler Academy it would help you
out a lot man yeah I mean part of part
of the struggle for us was like hiring
hiring was an incredibly long and
arduous process and now I feel like okay
we've got
two full-time long forums we have Olivia
doing short form Nick head of Ops it's
uh
new era is about to happen which is
really exciting and then after that we
have I went to CSI Academy
so I solved a crime scene did you like a
real crime scene or like yeah what when
you say solve a crime scene I'm like it
could be a real crime scene uh I think
we asked if we could do like when we
were filming we're like oh if if uh if
something happens tonight can we like go
with you guys and film that like
absolutely not obviously we wouldn't
just you know for uh for the sake of the
victims and the families and everything
it doesn't make any sense
um but so we did the mock crime scene
and then one of our friends went to
Juilliard and he is like
extremely good actor he was actually on
Dexter as like uh the new season are you
guys familiar with Dexter yeah
okay you know how Dexter like finds
criminals and kills them himself he is
like one of the people in it has like an
arc as a villain and you know can you
share who it is yeah his name is Stephen
Robertson okay extremely talented so we
called him we're like would you like be
our bad guy
the last part of the video is me like
with a detective partner interrogating
him in character it's crazy and we sat
there for two hours because you know
like there was a coach there who like
briefed him and they're like this is
your character and this is like only
give them info when they really push you
in this way so it's a challenge for me
and also like you know he's acting his
ass off being a crazy person in the
chair is awesome that's really cool yeah
you should do LAPD for a day I did uh
scpd is one of our okay
um one of our one of our videos that um
Police Academy is crazy
absolutely crazy how does that compare
to boxing I would say that when I went
to Police Academy I was tased and pepper
sprayed and I would never do either of
those again I would I would rather I
would rather fight somebody let me say
this what was worse getting pepper
sprayed or tasered pepper sprayed by a
million miles
because when you get pepper sprayed I
hope no one watching this has ever
experienced this
it lasts for 48 hours 48 minutes they
don't tell you this you think oh you
just get pepper sprayed and then like
wipe it and then it's gone it activates
in your eyes
and then you start crying then it's in
your tears and it burns your skin
and goes down like your whole face and
then that lasts I want to say an hour
like searing pain really
and then it starts to subside but then
when you shower it reactivates in water
how and then when you're showering it
goes down your body
and burns a lot of other places further
down your body
it adds I'm like I see them just like
drinking milk or pouring like milk on
their face does that work at all or no
um I'm sure milk helps I I was not given
milk when I went to the police academy
and it was it's crazy is there nothing
that neutralizes that I feel like
there's like milk but again they didn't
they didn't have uh how come no one's
invented something that neutralizes that
like you get pepper sprayed sure but
there should be like like a serum or
something that like spray it on top of
it and it's just like that that's
probably I I wish I had that whatever it
is I'm just curious because like how are
there no long-term ramifications of like
a searing pain on your eyeballs I feel
like that's just not what human bodies
were made for I'm sure people have had
you know
you know long-term effects from this
stuff I I didn't but it it was long I
thought it was going to be like a five
minute ordeal 48 hours and I I was like
literally like crying in the showers
like oh my God it just won't stop it's
so bad
um but getting tased is actually way
better because when you're tased at
Police Academy it only lasts like
five seconds what does it feel like to
be tased
it feels like you are being electrocuted
and writing a jackhammer at the same
time like on a construction site your
whole body is
violently shaking and all of your
muscles are cramping
does it hurt at all to for those little
prongs that go in your body so for mine
I didn't actually get shot they clipped
it onto me
that's much better before under your
skin yeah uh no onto my clothes okay
yeah
but then the current goes between the
two prongs right wow so everything in
between I think it was like my shoulder
and my calf
yeah like literally I'm like like you
it's it's it's a
um
extremely violent sensation right but
the immediate pain of when you're
actually being tased is more intense
than the most intense part of pepper
spray but the pepper spray is a problem
because it lasts longer
yeah pepper spray is a problem because
it lasts longer if pepper spray only
lasted 10 seconds like
what I experienced when I was uh
voluntarily tased
um I I guess I would have done that
instead but uh getting tased in that
moment is is extremely nice goes blank
yeah yeah it it uh like you hear them
count down and then it just throws you
back and you're just shaking and all
your muscles are cramping and it's like
extremely painful but when they stop you
fall to the ground
and obviously like
you're in shock afterwards but
physically
it's over when it's over
do you have any other like random
phobias or trivial fears like I'm scared
of getting my blood drawn do you have
anything like that you know when I had
to get my blood drawn for Creator Clash
oh yeah sitting in the chair and I was
shaking like a chihuahua um are you
scared terrified well I just I just
don't like
I don't know I I does anybody like
getting their blood drawn I probably
some people just don't mind it yeah yeah
but it was okay I can't stand it yeah
not a fan of that I don't like heights
I don't like heights but like I've
skydived and how was that I feel like
terrifying what I've heard from people
that are scared of heights that have Sky
Dove if that's past tense is when you
jump out it's such a surreal experience
it's not like hanging over like the
glass Railing at like the mall the
second story of the mall like that's
different because it's actually a
feasible height but when you're jumping
out of a plane your mind just cannot
comprehend it so it's not even like fear
which is what you're feeling it's
something completely different like an
out of body out of mind experience it is
because the view is the same when you're
in a plane I'm a person who feels safe
in Planes I don't get plain anxiety but
when I look out I don't think I'm gonna
fall there so when you're in the plane
going up to skydive yeah it's really
freaky stepping off but once you're in
the initial Free Fall it's like this is
the view I have out of plane maybe
that's not the right way but like
whereas when you're standing on a cliff
or like over the railing at the mall you
can see the bottom it's more clearly you
can yeah you can relate and I feel like
bungee jumping is 50 times scarier
because oh my God I'm never gonna do
that you know what I mean never gonna do
that whereas skydiving also just getting
like whipped like that I'm not yeah I'm
not into that yeah what's the initial
feeling like when you're jumping out of
a plane like your stomach just go pretty
much and I and you it's like you're
screaming but nothing's impacted
like if I were to scream in this room
we'd hear the volume it would Echo off
the walls when you scream falling out of
a plane you can't even hear yourself so
you feel
completely powerless
I have no desire to do that
the highest I've ever jumped was a buddy
had a roof like this and then it had a
pool and they jumped in there I jumped
from the roof to the pool I didn't I
didn't think so at all but I remember
the feeling of just like your stomach
just goes yeah but then it lasted longer
than I felt like it should have yeah you
know like a roller coaster kind of goes
away this was like yeah still falling
and I'd imagine that to feel someone it
actually really hurt to hit the water I
bet hey I was not expecting that yeah
because I'm not expecting that we should
go skydiving in Vegas yeah you know you
guys no yes
this would be a great experience I have
no desire to no desire so what do you
say to someone like Graham right where
you are very comfortable being
uncomfortable Graham is an extremely
uncomfortable to get uncomfortable right
what would you say do you think it's
fine for him to live this life
in Comfort right not venturing out of
his box what would Andrew Tate say
[Laughter]
um
he'd probably say sign up for his course
or whatever which is also probably a
waste of money but um
you know if if you were scared to go
skydiving I would call Jack and say buy
the tickets let's all go and you
probably have Chris credit card and then
Grant would be like the Investments I
don't have Graham's credit card probably
no
um so yeah what would you say to Graham
do you think it's you know I think it's
fair to be scared of skydiving I I am
scared of it but if it's something where
you're like I want to do this before I
die you just gotta sign up like I don't
okay well then don't do it feel pressure
ever to do something that you don't see
finds value yeah I'd rather go to Japan
between the two I know that sounds like
I want to go to Japan why Japan
I've always wanted I'm saying if you
like something to do before you die I
want to go to Japan okay that would mean
that would be way more to me yeah yeah
not tomorrow but why not tomorrow when
is your next vacation do you vacation uh
well Tampa
it's a vacation for me so this is a fun
little exercise I think about this quite
often so everybody like they look at
Graham they look at garyvee they look at
certain people like that like you grind
you put yourself through challenges
every single day it's a 24 7 Gig stuff
like that and people see that as
extremely challenging and uncomfortable
right to work at such lengths right
every single day
for Graham it's not challenging at all
for Grant would be challenging to do the
opposite because this is now what has
become easy for him this is his
preferable life right so that's what I
think and I think for Graham even for
you after putting yourself through so
many different challenging steps is you
probably have like this very high
standard of like the next one wouldn't
it be extremely uncomfortable and
challenging for you to do something
exact like on the other end of the
spectrum for the same way that it would
be impossible yeah maybe something like
that in the same way that for Graham it
would be extremely uncomfortable to like
Lounge for a day you know what I mean
you could do a video eating McDonald's
Burger King and doing nothing but
watching TV
compared to all the other challenges
that would be really challenging for me
because I don't and I think in the same
way that I think skydiving would be
challenging for you is because I think
both of us in these unique situations
don't see a benefit in the outcome right
yeah I agree with that yeah it's
it is I I guess yeah like I
like are you enrolled like drive over or
something no no we're there last year
okay yeah there's nothing did you go to
Disneyland here it's like the same thing
it's the same thing yeah
oh we are going to be staying by the way
with uh Ben Mala for two days really oh
really oh that's nice is are they in uh
Tampa or she's in Clearwater
oh yeah so I'm doing it I'm doing a a
video with Ben vacation four year update
video with Ben mellow yeah
I love clearly oh and he's gonna give
his old clothes to Alex Oh that'll be
exciting Ben is this yep in case he's a
real estate mobile guy he's like he
looks like an Italian mob boss
huge both in height and in size yeah any
chain smokes cigarettes but he's a total
boss like wow yeah so clear water
Clearwater real estate there is pretty
nice some of it is yeah yeah it's not as
exciting I mean the thing is I compare
it to LA and so everything there is like
wow everything is like half off but uh
it is nice to be on the water oh my God
it's cool so he's right on the water
he's right on the water he's got this
like 20 million dollar house that takes
up three lots and the home is gonna be
like twenty thousand square feet Lazy
River he's got a lazy river that goes
through his backyard wow it is massive
and it's right on the water so he's a
river and an ocean
yeah oh and he also has a bowling alley
wow yeah oh my God
yeah I mean that place is it's literally
an idyllic town it's Where The Truman
Show was shot so is it I think so yeah
Clearwater wow that would be interesting
over there but yeah they filmed it I'm
pretty sure
that was a great that was a great movie
yeah yeah and guess who did um some of
the music Jack oh your man Philip Glass
oh who were you thinking my man who else
is my man Danny Elfman no no Philip
Glass oh yeah yeah so how long are you
gonna be in Florida then uh week six
days five days okay yeah I get there on
Wednesday come back uh you know that
next week yeah
awesome okay
yeah
so do you have any questions for me or
greater class or anything really yeah I
mean what's your advice to me ahead of
Creator Clash yeah uh I would say it's
the mental aspect I didn't treat myself
that well like mentally I was just like
tune it out don't talk about it don't
think about it like just get it over
with and I don't think that was the best
mindset to have I was so anxious that
like the entire day I was just like yes
it's finally gonna be over I was more
focused about just getting through it
than I was about like doing well I feel
so looking back I'd focus a lot more on
doing well yeah wow I just wanted it to
be over like I was so relieved
afterwards I'm like finally I think I'll
be relieved yeah I think I think we all
I think we all will be yeah but it's a
different experience than what you would
expect I think just like the crowd but
then again like you're listening to the
crowd cheering and stuff like that but
like it's seeing it like walking in that
room seeing all the people uh and then I
I felt self-conscious knowing that so
many people were watching me and like
everything I do like someone was gonna
see it yeah it's being filmed replay and
be like yeah
exactly uh and then I went into thinking
like if I throw more punches then I
might have an advantage but I just tired
myself out way too fast wow so
conserving energy yes you almost want to
be a little bit more conservative in the
beginning
um just I guess feel out your opponent a
little bit more versus me just like
going in and like I gotta do this
because if I throw more punches like I'm
not gonna get hit I hope that I have
that opportunity too because I you know
I would love for the first round to be
like
feeling it out but I have a feeling
it'll be
she wants an early knockout he could be
uh the other thing just make sure to
keep your hands up
please say I thought the same thing I
was like everyone's putting their hands
down why are they doing that like
because again you forget everything uh
but the most important for me is like
the right hand I put my right hand down
or when I would do a jab like I would
naturally jab right hand down it's just
like an instinctual sort of thing
watching it's so easy to be like
why didn't I do this or why didn't this
boxer do that thing and then when you're
in there yeah oh I'm also going to say
it does not help to watch the fights
before I think I would have done I think
when you're in the waiting room yeah I
think I would have done much better if
it were just I had no idea what's going
on
so I think I would have done better was
watching the fights before
that in
freaked you out you did it just stressed
me out yeah because I saw everyone that
was going out was coming back and like
they all had an injury and I'm like
what's my energy gonna be like and so
that's an awful head space and like you
know yeah in the Moment Like obviously
now looking back no one was seriously
injured and like everyone recovered
um but just watching that I think it
stressed me out even more and I just got
in my head about it definitely like
evokes
um like in Gladiator movies that's how I
felt when people are waiting to go like
fight a lion or whatever and then they
bring the body back of the person before
and you're just like in front of
everybody yeah that's how it felt to me
yeah because everyone you'd see them
come back and like uh I forget the one
guy's name but like he had a broken nose
and I was just like oh man that's nuts
[__] oh my God yeah
Haley who fought last year yeah
um she and I trained at the same gym one
of the wonderful things about this
extremely abbreviated fight Camp has
been I've gotten to train Inspire with
her which has been such a wonderful
that's fantastic yeah but um you know
we'll be you know one of us will go
first and the other will go second and
oh my God I I am
like I feel like we have a unique Bond
the two of us oh for sure and we we
share some of our we each have different
coaches but then we share some as well
and so I
I really hope that you know whether it's
me going first or her going that we can
feed off of each other and support each
other rather than be like oh my God you
got a broken house now I gotta go like
that yeah
exactly so if you could just avoid
watching I think that would help do they
have like TVs they did in mine yeah and
of course everyone is huddled around the
TV it's it's hard like because you hear
it and you can also hear it on the TV
and then you hear you hear the crowd
because your room at least my room was
like 60 feet away from the entrance of
the walkout for the walkout and so it's
like you just walk down the hallway turn
right and you're there and so we were
kind of going in and out you can kind of
peer out and see like what's going on
there but like and it's weird with the
delay too because you would hear that
like a few seconds before you would see
it on the screen so it's like you hear a
thing and you're like what just happened
you see it on the screen
my God yeah so if you can might just
type yourself up to like put on like
music or like air pods tune it out be by
yourself yeah um but then again in a
guy's locker room there were like 20
people in there they're gonna be like
three for you guys yeah it's gonna be a
lot easier a lot a lot of there are a
few other female fights so it'll be like
five of us I guess in each locker room
yeah so it might be a little bit easier
than than us for like 20 people in there
and then every fighter had like two to
three people with them so that's how we
got like such a big group people were
all like you know doing their warm-ups
and stuff like that wow yeah wow wow wow
so if you could just get headphones in
just zone out meditate just visualize it
I think that'll go a long way yeah
absolutely oh my gosh I I'm like getting
butterflies just thinking about it right
now that's crazy getting butterflies
like remembering
that's why I'll never do it again yeah
it's a good experience though I feel
like oh yeah I'll be there you're a
friendly familiar face so I can be like
crib yeah and you'll be like
get it together see I'm gonna be doing
that video if they allow me in your
locker room I have a feeling they won't
but if they do I would love to get your
take like before all of this or like
you're gonna see me vomiting in a trash
can
the one thing I will say Michael Reeve
said the issue and kind of so did I I
was very nervous my mouth is getting
very dry beforehand so I was drinking
water and I had the sensation of having
to go pee once they wrap once they wrap
your gloves I've heard of this and you
can't do anything yeah and so Michael
was talking about yeah he had his
trainer pull down his pants for him
that's gonna well he went to the
bathroom
so for me I think it was more of a
mental thing because I once I knew like
those gloves are wrapped you have like
30 minutes and and you want to be like
on your game it's like worse if you feel
like you have to go to the bathroom like
it's gonna throw you off and I was like
oh crap now I like this is gonna throw
me off is there anything else you guys
want to talk about yeah we'll just uh
wrap it up with something light
um what do you think is the meaning of
life
some light discussions yeah some easy
questions I think the meaning of life is
different for everybody I guess for me
it's similar to how I'm approaching this
boxing match where I don't ever want
like
days are a month or a year of my life to
go by where I feel like I could have
I I could have made it more of what I
wanted so not necessarily like like the
idea of
I I wish I could have done more but
I think for me it's like
is everything I'm doing and every day
and every moment fulfilling and exciting
because at the end of this I mean we're
all gonna die
and
nothing after that matters to me as an
individual
what do they call it the uh the age-old
adage where it's like if you're on your
deathbed you want to look back and and
be happy with all the decisions that
you're that you said yes to something
rather than displease that you said yeah
or something absolutely yeah I just
really wanna like
have a rich and exciting life of all of
whatever life has to offer
there how do you one-up this do you know
what's next yeah do you know what's next
after I mean we we definitely have like
a lot of fantastic videos coming after
this and this is going to be the longest
video I mean this is over a year of
footage which is crazy
um I don't know exactly at this point
like what the next like massive project
will be but I mean I've also learned
like some of the the best performing and
most impactful videos we make don't have
to take a year to make they can be shot
in a day so yeah I'm really open to
whatever honestly be a Race Car Driver
do F1 I want to do that yeah I also want
to do pit crew oh because they have
these facilities where pit crew are
trained and they like practice like
throwing the tires and this is you know
all that yeah I would do both of those I
think that would be so cool yeah
anything else you want to talk about I
guess I just want to say future me I
hope you're a winner
[Music]
[Laughter]
hour all of your links will be left down
below in the description if you want to
shout anything out if you want to shoot
anything out go ahead what do you want
to shoot out you can you can shoot me
out by subscribing to my YouTube channel
there we go I'll see what that said you
guys thank you so much for watching
links Down Below in the description feel
free to check them out and until next
time
that's fantastic lovely